Monday morning saw the UK's credibility
face the Judgment of markets three weeks
of chaos on a weekend of whiplash
u-turns has left Financial stability
economic policy and the fate of
ministers in the hands of investors to
sector the new Chancellor couldn't have
been higher Sky News understands at
least one pension fund would have been
threatened had UK guilt markets continue
to plunge ditching almost everything his
predecessor promised did the job for now
I think it's a a cautious vote of
confidence if you like I think it's a
relation how far that mini budget went
in unsettling markets they had to row
all of that back and say and we are not
about to do anything completely out of
the ordinary for a G7 economy for the
Finance Minister of G7 economy to say
that is quite something yields on
30-year guilts which spiked after the
mini budget fell back during the day
buying the chancellor time as he tries
to balance the books these guilt markets
matter because they set the cost of
government borrowing they're effectively
a vote of confidence in State's ability
to pay its way so the lower the yield as
it's called the lower the interest rate
the government pays on new borrowing or
maintaining existing debt so if this can
be stabilized or brought down it might
just might reduce the need for spending
cuts
they matter for mortgage holders too
come this way driving fixed rates higher
faster than expected even a month ago
Liam was caught as the tide turned by
the spring you may lose the cushion of
energy support too our percent has gone
up from one to four percent
um which represents I guess for us
around about 400 pounds extra a month to
find so over the year is definitely time
to tighten the purse strings if you like
um so yeah it's been been a difficult
one I feel like I've um you know for a
lot of lack of a better term definitely
how Japan's fall down to a degree
having reversed more than 30 billion
pounds of tax cuts the chancellor now
has to rebuild faith in the public
finances for the satisfaction of the
office for Budget responsibility I think
probably what he's found when he got the
forecast the draft forecast is that
there's a bigger hole than he'd expected
and he simply can't afford the rest of
the tax cuts which were included in the
mini budget
the Market's Force ministers to change
course and confidence lost in a month
can take years to restore for now every
day will be Judgment Day Paul Kelso Sky
News in the city of London